hi i'm evan carmichael and today i
wanted to talk about a topic
that a lot of entrepreneurs are scared
about but shouldn't be
and that's your balance sheet many
entrepreneurs
no balance sheet is something their
accountant gives them at the end of the
year
but they don't really know how to use it
to make important business decisions
so in this video i wanted to quickly
talk about what a balance sheet is what
the elements are
and then give you some tips and
strategies on how you can use the
information in your balance sheet
to run your business potentially raise
money for your business and also
sell your business here we go
to quickly explain what a balance sheet
is i've loaded my simply accounting
enterprise software
and you can go to reports click on
financials
over to balance sheet and this will help
me prepare a balance sheet for the
company
this is a construction company here and
there is the balance sheet
so the balance sheet will basically tell
you what your business
owns what it owes to other people
and then what you as a business owner
actually have
in the business that's left over so if
you look at the
assets here assets is what your company
will own
the liabilities are going to be what you
owe to other people
and then the equity is going to be what
you as the entrepreneur will own
in the actual business so the formula is
always
assets equals liabilities plus
equity or if you think about another way
the assets what your company
owns minus the liabilities what you owe
is
what you end up with as your equity in
in the company and hopefully
that's a lot of money so i want to
quickly just touch base on what each
category is so you have a
understanding under assets
you can look at the first category here
is total current assets
and this these are assets that are
either cash or could be converted into
cash really quickly
so you can see here cash is here and
then usually the biggest one in the
current assets are receivables
so accounts receivables are money that's
basically owed to you
now you've you've either invoiced them
and they're you're waiting on payment
could be 30 days or 60 days or 90 days
and you're waiting to get paid so
hopefully that'll be converted pretty
quickly
inventory assets is the second category
and these are items that you have that
hopefully can be converted quickly into
cash
if you need it so if we look at what
they have here
we've got drywall hardware lumber
roofing other
so it's a construction company that
would make sense if they really needed
to
generate cash they could probably sell
this and and make some money from it
the next category are capital assets and
these are items that you cannot convert
into cash
very easily but are still worth a lot of
money so you can see
on this balance sheet here that they've
got a lot of capital assets
so if you look at that you'll see things
like furniture
equipment vehicles computers building
land
so all things that have value but it's
hard to convert into money if they
really need to do it quickly
and then the last category are other
non-current assets
and these are things like goodwill or if
you have a patent that's potentially
worth a lot of money
you would filter it here under
non-current assets
the next side is liabilities and so this
is going to be what you owe
as a company again it's going to be
divided into current liabilities and
long-term liabilities
so for current liabilities this is money
that you basically will owe
within the next year so it could be
accounts payable
so something that you've bought that you
haven't paid off yet credit card debt
uh bank loans bank advances corporate
taxes
basically things that you need to pay
off within the next year
long-term liabilities uh is money that
you owe to other
people or other companies but that
aren't due until beyond a year
so it could be a bank loan or a mortgage
or a loan from a shareholder
things that you have to pay off but you
don't have to pay off within the next
year
so that's how much liabilities you'll
have and then the
remainder is going to be the equity and
that's going to be how much you will own
as the entrepreneur in the business so
again the key thing to look at
assets is what you own your company owns
liabilities
what your company owes to other people
or companies and if you subtract those
two you'll end up with the equity which
is how much you have actually left in
the business
so that's what a balance sheet is let me
now
show you how you can use the information
in your balance sheet
to run your business raise capital for
your business
and then potentially sell your business
as well
two important numbers that we can get
from our balance sheet to help us run
our businesses
are working capital and turnover in
accounts receivable
so we'll start with working capital
working capital you may have heard
before
it is basically your current assets
minus your current liabilities
so if we look at our current assets it's
350
000 almost minus our current liabilities
of two hundred and twenty thousand
dollars
so we've got some some good working
capital of about a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars what that basically
means is
this company can survive in the short
term so
if creditors come and say hey we need
our money now or if there's a
crunch that you know sales dry up and
the company needs to pay off
you know those liabilities they have the
money to do it
if you owe a lot of money in your
liabilities and you don't have money
coming in
if there's a big crunch if sales drop
off then it's going to be hard for you
to
raise the money to be able to pay people
off also being able to pay things like
salaries and day-to-day expenses are a
lot easier if you have
good working capital so you want to make
sure that your current assets
are greater than your current
liabilities and that'll help
ensure that your company can survive in
the short term
the second thing to look at is your
accounts receivable
and a big part of your current assets
here we could see
is our accounts receivable so for this
company you know we have 346 000 current
assets
accounts receivable is a big chunk of
that 236 000.
this could mean i'm getting money right
away or could mean
i'm not getting money for a long time so
you want to look at
how frequently that money comes in so
is it you know 30 days payable is it 60
days payable is it 90 days payable
because if you have a lot of liabilities
if you owe people money that's coming up
you know the bank needs their money
regardless then
you have to make sure that that money is
going to come in on time
the other thing you want to make sure of
is that people actually pay your
accounts receivable
and that you're working with companies
who will pay
on time so companies that you know don't
go bankrupt or refuse to pay you
you're still showing it here as hey you
know i'm over two hundred thousand
dollars
but if they don't actually end up paying
you the money then it's going to be hard
time for you to be able to run your
business
so those two key numbers are really
important to look at for growing your
business
again you want to look at your working
capital so your current assets minus
your current liabilities
and that'll tell you if you're able to
survive in the short term with your
business
and then look at your accounts
receivable and see when they're due
if the money is going to be coming in on
time for you to pay off what you owe
other companies and if it's likely that
that money will come in based on the
types of clientele that you're working
with
next up is raising capital if you're
trying to raise capital
from bankers or from investors they want
to definitely take a look at your
balance sheet
so you can make it as strong as you can
by first making sure that there's assets
to lend against so they won't care so
much about your current assets but they
want to look at your
capital assets to see if there's
anything that they can
lend against so especially bankers want
to see that you have a lot of
assets so if you have land or if you
have a building
or if you have any furniture equipment
that has some significant
value then they're thinking well if they
don't pay off this debt
i can take away that building i could
take away that land and sell it and i
can make my money back
they want to have that security that you
have an asset there that they can take
away from you if you don't make your
payments
so they want to make sure that you have
those capital assets available
the other thing that they're going to
want to look at is how much debt do you
already have
so they're going to look at your
liabilities especially the long-term
liabilities
and see do you already have bank loans
do you already have a mortgage you have
loans from shareholders
if you already have a lot of liabilities
and you're owing people a lot of money
it's going to be a lot harder for you
you to be able to raise capital because
even though you have great assets
you're already maxed out and it's harder
to leverage those assets even more
if you're trying to sell your business
the potential buyer is definitely going
to want to look at your balance sheet
so i want to talk about a couple things
you're going to want to look at
if we're looking at assets they're going
to definitely check out your current
assets and look at your receivables
so your accounts receivables they're
going to want to see how big is it
and do your clients have a history of
pain like yes well we have 236 000
in accounts receivable but you know our
clients don't often pay us on time or
don't pay us at all
then you're going to get that number
knocked back significantly
the other thing here is inventory assets
if you carry a lot of inventory
they're going to see what is the
likelihood that you're actually going to
use
all of this stuff in your business and
if they had to sell it for cash if
something happened and you had to get
rid of
you know your hardware for example could
you actually sell it for 98
000 is it worth that much or is it worth
a lot less if you're gonna sell
the actual hardware itself so they're
going to look at
every single number on your balance
sheet and start asking your question to
see if your company is actually worth
the amount that you say it's worth one
last thing to look at here
we had the other non-current assets this
again is patents goodwills
here it's also called intangible assets
they're called intangible because it's
really hard to get an actual value on it
how do you value what a patent is worth
so you might think it's worth a lot
often buyers will say you know zero
dollars i'm not giving any value
assigned to that so something to be
prepared for
the other thing if i just close this up
that a potential investor is going to
look at
is do you have a track record of success
so you can create a balance sheet for
every year that you've been in business
and hopefully you've been around for
a little bit and they're going to want
to see that you've grown the business so
that you've
you've gained assets and that you've
gained in your
equity so they can see that your
business is growing you're acquiring
more assets
it could be land and buildings and that
kind of stuff more equipment to grow the
business
and also it's great that you've acquired
more assets but
they want to see that you're reducing
your liabilities or at least your equity
is growing
faster than your liabilities so if your
assets are going up
then either your liabilities or your
equity have to be going up
so hopefully it's the equity side and
that's what your your own value in the
business is
instead of you financing the growth by
taking on tons of debt
a new a new owner doesn't want to come
into a business and have to pay off huge
amounts of debt
so they're typically going to want to
look at three years or five years growth
if you have that
if you don't have that then as much as
you can but definitely be prepared with
your balance sheets because it makes you
look a lot more professional
makes you look like a serious business
person and it increases the chances that
you'll be able to sell your business and
hopefully get a good price for it
thank you for joining me for this video
i hope you enjoyed and it gave you some
more information about what a balance
sheet is
and how you can use it to make important
decisions for your business
if you did enjoy the video please give
it a thumbs up below
i'd also love to hear your thoughts and
feedback if you want to leave a comment
and stay tuned for the next episode
you